reculer vous
pendant les six prochains mois
nous ne serons plus qu'un jet de lumière
déchirant l'espace et le temps
et ceux qui sont cryogénisé croiront
avoir répété ce voyage sera synonyme de
vie
première fois
tu veux un conseil d'ami casse toi mon
siège
ne vous exposez pas sans compter
tout le monde est mort et 50 millions
personnes
les derniers 50 millions si tu remarques
un comportement étrange mais tu me le
dis tout de suite
[Musique]
ils ne sont pas seuls
alors menti
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ce qu'on mérite
s'ils sont là on voit les éliminer
une force nouvelle contrôle et de
l'intérieur il n'est pas humain on y va
vous dégagez de ce vaisseau nous sommes
là pour traquer
nous sommes là pour survivre
je tiens à vous rappeler que si vous
êtes ici c'est parce que plus personne
ne veut de vous
la vérité c'est que la société sans
oublier bien sûr vos familles ont cessé
d'avoir confiance en vous ces gosses ne
sont qu'une bande de vauriens son coeur
j'ai un truc à contrer en particulier le
célèbre ordre du nid du corbeau il y en
a partout dans l'internât il se passe
quelque chose
il se passe de drôles de choses ici et
si jamais ça venait à se savoir
je suis prête à parier que ça ferait
scandale dans cette congrégation somme
investie d'une mission celle de lutter
contre le démon le démon sait exactement
quoi faire pour que nous b sur notre
garde et le mâle donne lieu à des
vilains explicable à des disparitions
le diable est absolument partout lorsque
les portes de l'enfer se décide à
sourire
c'est le mal qui règne alors en maîtres
et regarde quand même
[Applaudissements]
j'ai raté quelques uns et si tu as même
pas français
le garçon tu a renversé ce matin c'est
le fils de la plus dangereuse famille de
mafieux de toute l'histoire de cette
ville
personne ne doit rien savoir
pas de détour n'oubliez pas ce qu'on
vient chercher et ne fait confiance à
personne parce que c'est d'aimer vous
sentez parents qui appartient ce bébé
sérieux un bébé pickpockets haut
[Musique]
impressionnant toi tu va m'être utile
petit résumé de la situation
je m'appelle rail à notre pays est en
guerre depuis toujours notre peuple ne
parvient pas à s'entendre
ma fille je veux croire que l'esprit de
commandera est toujours là mais
quelqu'un doit faire le premier pas pour
instaurer enfin la paix nous devons
retrouver le dernier dragon
si vous avez l'intention d'aller broyer
le drone
je suis prêt on adore il faudra être
très prudent nous ne sommes pas les
seuls sur le coup
ces années de recherche
pourvu que ce soit bien là
et si soudée qui a parlé nous avons
vraiment besoin de vous je vais être
honnête avec toi suis pas comme qui
dirait le meilleur des dragons mais tu
connais le travail de groupe avec ce
camarade de classe qui n'affichent pas
une et qui à l'arrivée obtient la même
d'autre que toi on est mort
vous allez me suivre toit et la pierre
de dragon mon épée nous dit qu'elle
n'est pas d'accord
le monde sa magie
la confiance a disparu
peut-être que le monde va mal parce que
la confiance a disparu ou se doit de
faire le premier pas
puis métamorphoser les dragons peuvent
faire ça les regarde j'ai les fesses
tout près de la tête ça va accélérer la
digestion c'est bien
[Musique]
date de naissance le vendredi 31
décembre 1937
vous habitez avec votre fille en ce
moment c'est bien ça dans mon
appartement
vous voyez la situation est très simple
je vis dans cet appartement depuis 30
ans maintenant et ma fille aimerait
beaucoup qu'il soit à l nom de quoi
est-ce que tu parles pas pas alors elle
a emménagé avec cet homme qu'elle a
rencontré
je suis là pour t'aider pour m'aider à
faire quoi tout va très bien
anne j'ignore ce qu'elle complotent
contre moi mais elle complète quelque
chose j'en suis certain
il se passe quelque chose de be there
will tableau croyez-moi il se passe
quelque chose de bizarre
est ce que quelqu'un a vu ma montre on
me l'a volé sa personne la volée ça fait
un moment que ça dure des choses
étranges se produisent
qu'est ce que c'est que ce délire ou et
al mais du coup est-ce que tu parles
mais où est elle celui-là je n'ai pas
besoin que quelqu'un m'aide
il faut trouver une autre solution ne
peut pas continuer comme ça en dit pas
c'est si je ne quitterai pas de mon
appartement
je ne quitterai pas tournée passe avant
tout
a pas assez pris des pilules
peux vous poser une question combien
temps encore comptez vous rester ici a
gâché la vie de votre fille
qui es tu exactement
[Musique]
mais moi papa de
qui qui suis-je exactement
[Musique]
oh regardez là monsieur on le bouge plus
on s'est vraiment qu'elle s'est noyé
donc de faim disparus au cours de
l'année 1899 dans paris s'élève à 247
c'est pas un peu jeune pour enquêter sur
un meurtre
réfrène son orgueil on cède pas à ses
désirs de violence police ouvrez des
enquêteurs le quotiden moucharde la
pente est raide on gagne sa vie comme
formateur splendide pour le surtout
parisien le préfet lépine de retour aux
affaires
pourquoi voir et bien machel vous êtes
de retour au sommet
[Musique]
dreyfus va être rejugé la moitié de la
france va devenir folle à cette occasion
vous serez vous monsieur
le pays aura besoin
vous êtes trouvé pour la matrix ce qui
vous perdra fois que j'ai fait l'amour
un homme il en est mort et éplucher les
coquines est-ce que c'est bush fatale et
fiable j'avais confiance en toi vous
êtes autorisés à employer la force
seulement celui au nom de dieu va
envoyer un homme à la guillotine pour
étouffer cette affaire
[Musique]
m
c'est ce que pas ça comme une star ac
est intense match et à la pertinence car
c'est toi
[Musique]
l'accident